qué es ser un virus
se lo voy a explicar de una manera
muchísimo más sencilla
o se va a poner un pequeño infomercial
[Música]
está usted harto de esas dificultades
que hacen de su vida un interminable
calvario no voy a tener que soportar las
cuánto tiempo tendrá que aguantar esto
ya no tiene que preocuparse porque ha
llegado el nuevo el fin de la tarde
el interruptor 3000 convierte su
alrededor en un maravilloso espacio más
interesante y positivo ya que por sus
intersectores de espacio y sus
fraccionadores de tiempo logra crear una
casi imperceptible pero potente
interrupción alrededor y acá llevando su
atención a un grado superior de máximo
potencial creativo dándole la facilidad
y la libertad de disfrutar más su vida
para que seguir soportando estas
molestas situaciones que se acumulan una
a otra día con día cuando el remedio de
la distracción profesional de leasing de
raptor 3000 aporta en su diario y
cotidiano vivir otorgando a usted el
poder de decisión para minimizar estos y
otros desagradables aspectos de su
existencia bien seguro que le cortaron
porque realmente son información muy
largo pero la idea es ese virus que
empezó como un proyecto de arte hace
unos casi 2018 no sabíamos qué estamos
haciendo realmente lo que queríamos era
interrumpir era 2018 se acuerdan de 2018
que está la violencia y está el fórum de
las culturas estábamos 2 2008
estamos aburridos y la ciudad era
aburrida para nosotros éramos una bola
de creativos gente que sea cine y nos
llamamos los narvales y creamos esta
pieza para interrumpir los espacios y
bueno se llevó a un lugar muy fantástico
que es un virus una persona que busca
infectar su entorno y que realmente no
sabe qué está haciendo y que repite
ciertos patrones hasta poder llegar a
infectar un sistema un virus no es un
virus hasta que reconoce su entorno y el
potencial que tiene para poderlo
infectar todo el mundo aquí tiene el
potencial de infectar su entorno su
calle su esquina su barrio
les vamos a presentar a los virus
afortunadamente yo me puedo reproducir
fácil porque tengo un hermano y él es
hermano se parece mucho a mí y pensamos
casi igual él es ingeniero
yo soy licenciado
empezamos con el primer virus que es el
león de tampiquito que están viendo aquí
y utilizamos muchas líneas para saber
qué estábamos haciendo con este pedazo
de yeso para provocar una calle provocar
ser más románticos cotorrear sela vivir
la vida un poco más ligera y tener una
cosa como esta interrumpiendo tu casa
interrumpiendo tu sala entre un cliente
oficina y preguntándote qué es qué hace
y cada quien inventaba sus historias
hola soy el león de tampiquito lo pueden
buscar como el hashtag como tal y les
vamos a explicar un poquito lo que
quería hacer este elemento es el
registro que hice rené medina realmente
la documentación fue demasiada para este
pieza lo llevamos como puede decir al
mar
entonces está esta pieza interrumpe un
espacio y crea que el espacio sea
diferente por alguna razón no sabíamos
qué razón entonces era una pieza de arte
que terminó siendo un símbolo de un
barrio tú vas caminando cualquier barrio
y de repente te encuentras esa pieza y
dices que es qué está haciendo ahí que
representa y empezar una cantidad de
rumores y cosas que era lo que nos
encantaba que sucediera
te lo pasas por ahí
y bueno era el fórum de las culturas
como el repito y la idea y bueno vamos a
intervenir toda la ciudad y que la gente
todo todo el mundo iba a llegar a
monterrey pues todo el mundo pues
obviamente yo la verdad montañas y si
todo el fondo lo que tú quieras pero se
encontraban con esta cosa que no sabían
que era y que les causaba esa curiosidad
y además por si vive el compadre de
áfrica dice oye pues vi una cosa le tomé
fotos no sé qué es lo reproducimos
sacamos el molde y pues éste no sucedió
entonces la idea era ponerlo ahí ahí
y también ahí en esa intersección y era
eso
lo mismo existe por falta observación
ves esa intersección tan sencilla pero
si pones una cosa como éstas dice aquí
se volvió tu vida cotidiana en algo
extraordinario hoy vamos a poner ahí y
bueno llegamos al barrio de tampiquito
lo pusimos ahí y a ver qué pasaba y
sucedió algo extremadamente
extraordinario para nosotros hasta los
poníamos en un mapa donde iban a estar
todos los leones pero no voy a mencionar
las autoridades que no quisieron hacer
esto como saben nos dedicamos a retar
las autoridades y sucedió que se
convirtió en un símbolo de tampiquito y
como no nos hicieron caso aquí en
monterrey por lo que vamos de viaje
todos esos amigos que iban o yo voy para
china debate uno voy para llevarte otro
y así no y así es mi hijo ha cargado el
león le hacemos un pañal y listo se lo
llevaban y sucedían a las personas que
cargaban un león suceden cosas
extraordinarias también
esta tiene el pompidou en milán
en hollywood en fin hay una cantidad de
fotos que no voy a pasar entonces
despierta la curiosidad y me represento
como lo mismo existe por falta
observación cualquier lugar que tú ves
que te parece cotidiano si hay algo que
tú puedes hacer para romper esa visión o
esa imagen hazlo con cualquier cosa o tú
mismo
si lo ven
ven también los tenis que están colgados
es casi lo mismo
no más que los tienes ya nos
acostumbramos a verlos está
interrumpiendo el espacio
también podemos encontrar así
entonces empecé como un proyecto de arte
y terminé como un símbolo de hecho
terminamos haciendo septet prevención'
elementos design y hay uno de los
preceptos que es identidad le dimos
identidad a un lugar sin quererlo ese es
un virus que provocó el león de
tampiquito que pueden leerlo pero una de
las cosas más increíbles que provocó es
que alguien encontró novia
del león y vemos estamos una feria maco
y nos llevamos cargado porque la idea
era venderlo todas las galerías de arte
y que no les vendíamos el proyecto y
repente nos vean un cuate ya el tercer
día del evento
obviamente mi hermano y yo pues nos
habíamos ido de fiesta bastante este y
traemos a lyon con nosotros se nos acabó
el dinero llega un cuate un chilango y
se oye pues cuando por el lyon el es de
15 mil pesos unos de los 5 mil pesos y
se fue y ya no se tiene nada más de él
hasta que nos encontró por redes
sociales y nos dice me voy a casar y por
culpa del león llegó un café de la
condesa lo puso al lado él iba caminando
por él le preguntaban él lo que quería
era interacción y aún a una muchacha y
le pregunté cuando conecté él inventó
una historia y se enamora
una de las cosas más increíbles que él
se dio gracias a que estábamos haciendo
esta intervención de espacios es que
este es este pedazo de yeso llevó a la
bienal de venecia fue algo bastante
increíble para nosotros como un elemento
de barrio un elemento de identidad aquí
estoy yo utilizando por primera vez mi
self eastick
que creo que en venecia es la única
manera que puedes comprar un sofisticado
hacemos otro tipo de virus también y son
los que recordamos y los que encontramos
realmente somos malísimos para
documentar nos y registro de lo que
nosotros llevamos porque un virus
de alguna manera lleva un poco de enojo
con el virus está infectando obviamente
lo digo en singular porque una de las
potencialidades o lo que el wanna be de
un virus es ser un virus un virus
positivo entonces hicimos este proyecto
que unirnos y alguien recuerda el inside
out the year que pues prácticamente
ponía fotos de personas en muchas partes
del mundo y lo implementamos fuimos
elegidos como barrio después ha decidido
vamos a hacerlo empezamos
tomando fotos y que era para esto íbamos
a aparecer ahí y todo iba muy bien ese
virus e iba muy bien nos empezamos a
poner las en las fachadas del barrio
tampiquito pero oh sorpresa no fue
recibido como nosotros pensábamos los
vecinos empezaban a ver que las personas
estaban en blanco y negro y pensaban que
estaban muertas
son personas fallecidas y luego vecinos
que no salieron en la foto se enojan y
luego fueron al municipio y luego sin
una queja y luego un ciac y luego ya los
tuvimos que quitar
es era algo que nosotros pensamos que
iba a crear identidad que de cierta
manera no pedimos permiso lo hicimos y
no fue así pero aún hoy en día hay
vecinos que recuerdan yo estuve en esa
pared y eso nos da mucha satisfacción
evolucionó el virus después de varios
años de andar poniendo leones por los
techos de las casas
empezamos a conocer vecinos y es
interesante cómo te acercas a los
vecinos con algún totalmente diferente o
cómo te acercas a un entorno totalmente
diferente sin tratar de resolver un
problema el que no ve que esto está mal
hay que resolverlo encuentra la cara de
virus a eso y saber qué puedo hacer en
ese espacio que no tienen absolutamente
nada que ver pero va a crear una
interacción
entonces cómo lograr que los vecinos se
conozcan de hacer la pregunta sin que
sea por un problema quién de aquí se
reúne con sus vecinos levanten la mano
bien poquitos normalmente no nos
reunimos por un problema no
hay un problema no es que los copos de
las de los perros y es que están robando
y siempre es un problema y no era algo
tan
pacheco como un disco lo vamos a poner
arriba de tu casa
entonces empezamos a hacer un poco de
design thinking tenemos un background de
urbanismo y de mercadotecnia y de cómo
realmente pinchar una idea y la idea es
enseñarle a los vecinos saber cómo
pinchar sus ideas a cualquier instancia
de cualquier institución entonces
empezamos al algo así como design
thinking y es una dejamos design team
team vecinal en pro de una vez y no
gracias diferentes si no saben lo que es
vecino gracias y entonces alguien sabe
por qué esos colores se llama cómo se
llama
interesante como sé porque se llama la
maria luíza seguramente hay una persona
y le creamos una leyenda
entonces enseñamos a cómo hacer su mapa
cómo hacer sus temas cómo hacer sus
delimitaciones y su mapa de actores poco
a poco de manera analógica les llamamos
un mapa datos del ine que de una manera
muchísimo más legibles estamos
obviamente apuntalados a zonas
vulnerables todos los desarrollos de
informes que están en medio de la nada y
que no tiene cero identidad les
empezamos a hacer su logo les entregamos
un kit para enseñarles a usar el post-it
es bastante importante cómo solicitar
apoyos cómo presentar sus ideas al
gobierno como contarse y empezar a tener
otro tipo de diálogo más allá del
problema
este es el kit de cómo se entrega que
realmente son mesas y sillas y una caja
con chartis etcétera etcétera y un
gafete y un manual que poco a poco se
dice desde que empezamos con la visión
cómo hacer sus páginas de facebook
también bastante interesante y la mata
de todos como realmente hacer un grupo
de whatsapp que realmente funcione tiene
que pertenece un grupo de guasa de
vecinos
venden de todo no es como les enseñamos
de que vecinos generales seguridad el
proyecto
el ser 13 3 y sobre todo el general que
sucedía todo entonces realmente si si lo
hacen de una manera adecuada en el df
con seguimos trabajando ya los policías
están dentro de los whatsapp estos
imagines el potencial que eso provocó
por el hecho que convencimos a un
policía estará dentro del grupo de
whatsapp y luego luego este carro esta
persona y van a los índices de violencia
empezaron a bajar entonces el whatsapp
vino a revolucionar la vida vecinal otro
proyecto que también hicimos aquí en el
centro de monterrey era la idea era
pasarla bien en un edificio que se llama
edificio monterrey o urban ya que ahora
se le conoce y nos metieron ahí como
virus a ver qué hacíamos
sí sí sí es un sarcófago con chelas
adentro son 125 almas que viven en este
edificio en el primer cuadrito está en
la calle para así y morelos realmente
mucha gente no lo ve porque morelos es
peatonal y nunca vueltas para arriba
pero este vecino tenía este tipo de
negocio dijo oye pues pongo este este
como parte de la fiesta y dos personas
que tenía necesidad contactaron de un
sarcófago desea mente lo contacten les
le da un descuento cosas maravillosas
pasan cuando los vecinos se conocen es
la parte de pues nice podríamos tomar
adentro y no tomar adentro porque
previamente había alcohol
aquí pueden ver eso
cuando un virus infecta poquito nos
hablan otros vecinos prendidos como
universidades gobiernos o empresas dice
ley yo quiero que hagas esto ahora le va
empezamos a hacer el proyecto les
empezamos alto la inteligencia de final
por ejemplo en la purísima empezamos a
reunirlos y a reunirlos ya tener todo
este design thinking pero no sucedió y
las expectativas de los vecinos se
quedan muy altas y el que nos contrató
pues no cumplió con la promesa nosotros
simplemente decimos aquí está la
inteligencia vecinal esto es lo que
reclamamos y nos retiramos
desgraciadamente entonces a veces el
virus que estamos tratando de provocar
no se lleva totalmente a cabo pero
infectamos un poquito
que sigue el fin del virus no sabemos
realmente nos queremos posicionar como
la primera asociación civil que tiene
fecha de caducidad vimos que hay muchas
acciones civiles que hacen cosas
extraordinarias pero continuamente están
bajando apoyos apoyos y si asistimos al
gobierno vamos un poquito en contra de
ello queremos hacer algo muy puntual
dejarlo ahí y que sea sustentable
queremos reproducir el kit del vecino
prendido que él repite su manual y
traducirlo en muchos idiomas una vez que
hagamos eso y una vez que hagamos algo
tan sencillo como es decretar el día
nacional del vecino fiestas en todo
méxico prácticamente y eso provoca el
encuentro aquí estamos haciendo un
prototipaje para la fiesta la el decreto
del día nacional del vecino
y donde se incuban todos estos virus hay
un lugar donde se incuban estos virus
todas estas personas que llegan y de
alguna manera se inspiran y en la nave
tampiquito
al cerrar los ojos por un momento y
luego aplicar una historia bien rápida
cerremos los ojos tantito
imagines un lugar que huele a café
imagínese un lugar que donde huele a
café también puedes reparar tu coche
si eres vegano puedes comer también
vegano
quiere desayunar también puede desayunar
mismo lugar al momento que ves el mejor
carro eléctrico de tu vida
tienes hambre y quieres comprar unos
huevos orgánicos también lo puedes hacer
en el mismo lugar
luego adelante quieres jugar un poco de
ping pong de mesa con pie y también lo
puedes hacer el mismo lugar tienes un
perro y quieres que coma de una manera
mucho más saludable también te venden
comida cruda para tu perro
y la última cosa que también puedes
hacer es jugar ping pong es el lugar
existe pueden abrir los ojos
está enclavado en el barrio tampiquito
el barrio está en piquito es un lugar
dentro del barrio y dentro del municipio
de san pedro
hacemos un farmers market hacemos un
fresco fest obviamente lo hacemos en la
canícula
el ceviche fest y próximamente en
febrero el sopa fest
todas estas festividades lo que queremos
hacer es que la gente se encuentre que
existe un lugar de encuentro neutral de
clases sociales y que de alguna manera
compartan ciertas ideologías
durante todos estos años queremos que
estos dos virus tanto mi hermano como yo
hemos evolucionado se crea un virus
urbanista hoy en día se llama luis
álvarez él está aquí trabajando esto es
parte de su trabajo y lleva a todos
estos urbanistas y todos estos
arquitectos que van a ser una plaza o
van a ser un edificio las constructoras
y los desarrolladores el trata de
infectarlos con una manera diferente de
hacer las cosas el siles ven y échate
una carne asada en la obra gris el aura
gris imagina que puede ser obviamente
utiliza muchas cosas de design thinking
que hemos aprendido pero es el mismo
principio en que está haciendo la carne
asada
aquí está el equipo que está infectando
el otro me considero un virus
comunitario soy yo realmente no sabemos
a dónde yo donde iba a acabar pero acabé
tratando de convencer a personas a que
compartan su coche quien de aquí
comparte el coche base carpool
un poquito realmente nuestra calidad de
aire está por los cielos y queremos
brillo estoy tratando de hacer algo que
emocionante que dos personas que no se
conocen ahora comparten un coche y que
por medio de este algoritmo que está
haciendo la empresa box se encuentren
vecinos que hace un radio de tres
kilómetros te vas a encontrar ese vecino
por medio de la aplicación que va el
mismo lugar a la misma hora vamos bien
lento no es algo sencillo y estoy
tratando de convencerlos repito nada
sencillo hacerlo
entonces para poderte convertir en un
virus tienes que repetir ciertos
patrones constantemente a lo mejor no
sabes que estás haciendo pero repite
ciertos patrones a lo mejor no sabes que
eres un virus pero repite ciertos
patrones y éstas sobreviviendo las
circunstancias de tu entorno entonces
estos son los cinco cosas que a mí me
gusta hacer una de ellas es compartir si
no compartes no te estás divirtiendo esa
es la premisa del virus que me reconozco
si ustedes realmente se están
preguntando qué puedo hacer yo ahorita
por mi entorno infectado con algo con un
póster con un flyer con lo que tú
quieras yo le ya lo he visto en varios
lugares hazlo tú entorno saliendo de tu
calle eso es lo que realmente te mueve
te sientes esa pertenencia yo hice eso y
lo van a ver todos los días entonces
realmente los estoy invitando a que más
desee de ser ser más yo seamos más todos
gracias
[Aplausos]